we're here with grandmaster alejandro
ramirez alejandro it's your first u.s.
chess championship do you think that
gives you any sort of disadvantage or
any way I think in some ways I'm just
not as used to some players on playing
strong events I've been playing a lot of
opens in the past few years and I think
that having played a strong closed
events in scores and that was back in
2005 do you think your style is more
suited towards open since you've played
them those before or you know honestly
I'm a little worried about that
you know I've had really aggressive
openings with black especially like the
Banco gambit where I just need to really
win with black and mini opens and you
know this is a closed event so I really
could just draw with all of my black
games so it might it might actually give
me very interesting games and we'll just
see how it comes out for those viewers
that don't know you have a degree in
video game creation I'm sure there's a
more technical term for your degree but
do you know of any other stronger
players that are in that field we have
tons of lawyers and doctors but any of
our chess players that do what you do no
not really ever masters in Arts and
Technology specialized in video game
design I worked on the Diablo 3 project
which is actually coming out during the
tournament it's going to be a kind of
difficult for me to handle both things
but as far as I'm concerned there's not
that many chess players really in any
creative artsy industry that I'm really
aware of which is funny because you know
chess is supposed to be not only a
science but also a sport and an art so
you have you don't have to justify
playing video games like the rest of us
do you just get to do it and call it
work it sounds like and it's it's a very
common thing in the video game industry
that you have to play games to keep up
with what's going on what would that
translate to in the chess world is level
30 like 1800 is that show competency or
it's really kind of like well it's money
you can make for viewers it's funny
because it depends on the game
and they've really based off of chess
many video games look at our rating
system and directly based themselves off
of that so for example a level 30 in
this league of Legends game is basically
what it would mean to get a feeder
rating and from there on you get ranked
inside that based entirely on the chess
system you had to switch your Federation
to the u.s. to be eligible for the
tournament here was eligibility for the
tournament one of the main reasons that
you switch I feel that this is my home
I've been living fairness where I want
to live in many ways I want to play for
the u.s. first of all the US
Championship is a big deal for me not
only that is the prize good I mean it's
just such a good event so pleasant to
play but also gives me the motivation to
try to make the US Olympic team great y
know us chess fans are hoping that
you'll add to the strength of the team
but good luck in your first arrest chess
championship well thank you very much
you